never know when computer disaster will
strike in fact every year more than
seven million computers crash in the US
alone so how do you protect your
valuable files such as digital photos
music and financial documents hard drive
crash viruses theft lawnmowers and other
form of disaster simple you backup your
files with mozi mozi is a safe and easy
way to automatically backup all of your
files online will even give you two gigs
of backup space for free
that's enough to backup more than a
thousand photos or music files to get
your free backup space visit the Molesey
website below mozi online backup funny
name serious protection